big public schools ranked really highly
on our list for the second year in a row
the university of california berkeley
which ranked number one last year moved
to the number two spot
ucla uc san diego and uc davis also made
it into the top 30
and so did some other big public
universities like the university of
michigan ann arbor and the university of
florida while these public universities
move up in the rankings they unseat
several high-profile private colleges
that have topped our lists in years past
harvard university which had been a
perennial number one on forbes top
colleges list sits at number 15 this
year yale university dropped six spots
from number two to number eight
in princeton university the university
of pennsylvania and northwestern
university each moved down one spot
so that shift is likely due to some
methodology changes that we made last
year
so that our list took into account
affordability and accessibility for
low-income students
two measures that look at return on
investment and graduation rates reward
colleges for enrolling a greater
percentage of low-income students
on average 25 percent of the students
enrolled at colleges on our list receive
pell grants which is often used as a
proxy measure for low income status
by comparison only 11 of students at
harvard receive pell grants
so this year the massachusetts institute
of technology topped our list
moving up from number six last year
alumni from the private university in
cambridge reported high median earnings
6 years and 10 years post enrollment and
earnings variables make up 20 of our
ranking model
only 8 of students take out federal
loans to attend mit and the university
also had 56 people on the american
leaders list which is a list we keep it
forbes that measures the leadership and
entrepreneurial success of the graduates
we had about a dozen new schools make
our list this year including the fashion
institute of technology in new york the
university of south dakota and belmont
university in nashville tennessee
some colleges made some really
impressive leaps in our rankings as well
for example hope college in holland
michigan rose 149 spots to number 290
the new jersey institute of technology
rose 114 spots to number 75
and lewis and clark college in portland
oregon made the biggest gain
rising 245 spots to number 263
this year we decided to break out the
five federal military service academies
such as the united states military
academy in west point and the united
states naval academy in annapolis
maryland because they operate quite
differently from other colleges on our
list and we're missing too much data to
make a fair comparison
for example students at these schools
don't take out federal loans but instead
they promise to serve five to eight
years in the military post-graduation
that said when we do compare them
against the rest of our list they
perform really well the military academy
would have made it into the top 10 and
the naval academy would have been in the
top 30.
[Music]